in this morning's eye on the money the
irs has launched new online tools to
help millions of families manage cash
payments
they could soon receive from the
government the american rescue plan
passed by congress in march
increases the maximum child tax credit
from two thousand dollars per child
it goes up to thirty six hundred dollars
for each child
under six and three thousand per child
ages
six to seventeen the program begins
paying families monthly starting july
15th
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger is here to walk us through
the key details good morning jill
long time no see i want to get straight
to it
besides the dollar amount what's the
biggest difference in terms of this
year's child
tax credit this enhanced credit
is divided into two payments in half
and families that are entitled to it
will be starting to get
six monthly checks okay so starts july
15th you'll get
half of that credit from july through
december
and then the other half of the credit
you will claim
when you file taxes next year so this
is quite different because in the old
tax credit you just filed your tax
return
so again half and half starts up july
15th
and who exactly qualifies for this new
child tax credit payment
well of course it's called the child tax
credit so you've got to have a kid
under the age of 17 by the end of this
year so by december 31st
you have to have had a child okay but
then there are
income thresholds and these are really
important
if you are a single filer you will get
the credit if you have
up to seventy five thousand dollars of
income
for head of households one hundred
twelve five
and for married filing jointly 150
000 so those are the qualifications i
also want to make sure people understand
if you didn't file taxes there are some
americans who don't have to file taxes
there is a tool a portal for the irs at
the irs.gov website and you can actually
put your information in there and that
will entitle you to the credit
well that certainly is my next question
to jill which is what do families need
to do to get this money
the vast majority of people birthday boy
oh you see i slip that in there
uh the vast majority the first the vast
majority of people don't have to do
anything and
now this is really predicated on what
has happened in the past so
if your income is about the same as it
was last year
if you have the same number of kids your
address your bank account information
you really don't need to do anything the
irs is proactively going to take action
however if something has changed you do
want to go over to that irs website
irs.gov again it's the child tax care
portal
and you want to change the information
so the reality is that if you have a
sort of a similar situation
no action if there is new information
update
we mentioned the higher end thresholds
for qualifying on the lower end i was
reading even if you don't make enough to
pay
federal income tax you still qualify
it's totally refundable i wanted people
to know that
um if the irs says you qualify but then
your income went up over this past year
jill what do you do
this is really tricky because this is
unlike
anything we've seen in the past so a lot
of people made
lower amounts of money last year during
the pandemic
maybe your old information that the irs
has would make you qualified but this
year you might have been
making you might be making more money so
you are being asked by the irs to
actually
opt out this is incredibly important
because you have to be proactive
so to opt out you go to the irs.gov
website and there is a form there you
just click
through it and the only reason you're
opting out is because you
think you make too much money this year
to qualify for the credit
now i would advise that if you think
you're sort of on the bubble you're not
sure whether you qualify or not
you can still opt out and that way next
tax season if you do qualify
you can get that full credit but it's
better not to get the money this year
because if you get it
and you don't qualify you have to pay
back that money to uncle sam next tax
season
yup time joe thank you very much jill
schlesinger